pour les téléspectateurs j'aimerais
qu'on fasse lâche on note jean-pierre la
journée jean pierre pernaut quand il
faisait le jt est maintenant à quelle
heure vous réveiller quand vous faisiez
le jt 6h10 6h du matin car vous avez
maintenant à quoi je m'attends six ans
vers 9h30 c'est arrivé est ce que ça
fait du bien ça fait énormément de bien
maintenant j'ai un emploi du temps un
peu plus tôt ensuite à 6 heures réunion
faisait quoi quand vous et les jt je me
dépêchais j'écoutais les radios les
télés etc
là je continue fait quoi maintenant deux
dernières parties doivent jouer à la
playstation 2 pris un petit fifa non
j'ai joué au tarot sur mon téléphone
d'accord et puis après je vais au bureau
quand même parce que jean perret vous ça
se prépare pour le sel dont vous allez
au bureau à quelle heure maintenant
bonjour vers 10 heures le matin 9h30
chez certains journaux woerth certains
jours on veut nous c'est bien quoi fui
je vous êtes heureux oui très vraiment
c'est vrai bien réagi péter reid le site
internet qui cartonne avec les bourgs
pour nom et puis à tf1 je vais partir la
semaine prochaine un tournage pendant
une semaine aux maldives pour faire un
reportage qui sera diffusé dimanche et
après bien sûr échangé aucun regret
alors dans son livre on apprend plein de
trucs à vous allez rigoler qu'est-ce que
vous avez le surnom qu'on donnait à
jean-pierre quand il était au lycée on
l'appeler sans leur père ou la paix john
paraît que vous appeler john parce que
vous ressembliez à john lennon avait
déjoué l'époque à vos débuts dans la
rédaction de tf1 quels mots familiers
péjoratif utilisé les mauvaises langues
pour qualifier les équipes de jean
pierre nous paraît qu'au départ vous
appelez les bouseux mais alors tout ce
qui faisait partie de l'équipe de jean
pierre muller épouse dès qu'on sortait
de vouloir payer fait qu'on était
déboussolé pour sortir du périphérique
fait un reportage
il fallait mettre un casque de brousse
sauf pour aller au festival de cannes
rejoindre notre ami bernard alors on y
aller festival de cannes les parisiens
allaient festival de deauville
sinon on allait pas en régionale et à
l'étranger sur les grands compliments
région n'y avait jamais alors y'a un
humoriste a osé écraser des jeux sur
votre tête en pleine émission c'est
michel michel baylet me retourne à 9,9
est-ce qu'il savait le cadeau qui a reçu
jean pierre pour son départ de tf1
rien bien reçu un cadeau et ouais je le
dis ici c'est une réplique de l'immeuble
de tf1 ouais on chocolat exactement ils
ont ils ont eu très très peur non mais
c'est vrai j'ai vu et on va voir les
images de votre mariage ce que notre de
votre mariage un chantier jean pierre et
nathalie ont surpris ils sont ils ont
été surpris par un paparazzi ouais c'est
ça c'est quoi l'histoire
non il ya un paparazzi qui avaient passé
la nuit dans l'église pour poursuivre
les paparazzi à l'époque et ça s'est
calmé depuis
maintenant les photos les met nous mêmes
sur les réseaux sociaux social voilà il
était qu'il y en a qui avaient passé la
nuit dans l'église et puis quelques
autres qui avaient essayé de rentrer
dans la soirée de mariage on les avait
un peu sorti c'est oui oui je sais pas
si il n'y a que moi on chauffe c'est un
peu un peu un peu mer un gâteau au
chocolat pour 33 ans de jt a eu de
noyades au sac de voyage faut que je
puisse faire
puis j'avais plein de cadeaux aussi pour
mes 30 ans il ya trois ans donc on va
pas recommencer des gros cadeau de
l'accord sur et